what I don't think people understand in
this country is that a lot of what
you're watching is theater this is
theater this is to keep you guys
entertained and the money people behind
this are just doing whatever they're
gonna [ __ ] do either way either way
they're doing whatever they're gonna do
mom and dad who are those big
billionaire families they're doing
whatever that bedtimes whatever time it
is you can negotiate to you you know
maybe you stay out a little longer
whatever they don't care you're not
really moving them off their course
dramatically meaningfully and if you do
they will come the gnashing of teeth
will be extreme and this is like people
like the Mercer's people like the cokes
people like you know George Soros on the
other side they all have an idea of how
the world should be run and they don't
go out to people and say this is how it
is they recruit people and they take
applications and they cast people this
key there's one kid from parkland but
one right-wing kid from Parkland Kyle
Kossuth who was how come we need more
guns I mean that guy God loved them that
dude he wasn't in the building that was
shot into he was in like another
building he's like listen we gotta I
love that because you know the NRA loves
de Lawd they're like wait you'll say why
you you'll do what you'll do what oh
really
great so he's out there saying arm
everybody give everybody automatic
weapon that's his answer just throw
those [ __ ] it's the Wild West kick
open the saloon doors at your own risk
buddy and so you have this kid now but
here's the thing Kyle loves saying the
n-word he loved it he said it on uh-oh I
don't know where he said it but he said
it on his snapchat he said no snaps
disappear what's the other I don't know
whatever but they got or it was a game
as gaming Xbox Live at the gay Xbox Live
he was letting it fly let it fly on Xbox
Live and in real
in real life too we just walk up to
people he would say the n-word
frequently so they found that they went
and go hey hey hey so what happens
I think Turning Point USA I think he
resigned so again he's out because you
serve at the pleasure of the
billionaires who back you that is it
that is what you're out here doing this
is theater this is to keep people
entertained and to keep people thinking
that there's real debate and discussion
in this cut there really isn't there's
really not a lot of debate and
discussion about what's gonna happen in
this con I know you'd like to think
there is you're like this is everybody's
at each other's throats yeah maybe in a
[ __ ] grocery store but in Washington
DC they're pretty much on the same page
there's a few things that they like to
argue about abortion in Alabama and in
Georgia there's a few real hot buttons
should gay people adopt kid there's a
few things but when it comes to foreign
policy economic policy the rights of
corporate America they are pretty much
Nancy Pelosi in her Georgetown town
house or with her millionaire husband
and San Fran we're [ __ ] Laurel Umar's
climbing in her kitchen window I mean by
the way how did not like Laurel umer a
little bit how do you not respect
Laurel umer a tiny bit she's the chick
who takes it too far that she's the girl
on your block that would hang out with
the boys and would kind of do anything
if you know what I mean to have friends
like you'd be like eat this bullfrog and
she'd be like okay should I put it in my
[ __ ] and you're like oh my god you'll
she'll just put it in your [ __ ] she's
like yeah I can hang out with you guys
right so this [ __ ] is climbing in Nancy
Pelosi's [ __ ] kitchen window because
they threw her off Twitter and again
none of it like it's none of it really
mad
in Nancy Pelosi and Donald Trump have a
lot more in common with each other and
they have a lot more in common with
even Colbert then people have in common
with uh you know of my uncle Larry
for example uncle Larry doesn't have a
ton in common with Nancy Pelosi Trump
Colbert there's there's there's just not
a lot in common but this is the thing
that people love to get involved they
get invested there's YouTube shows that
cover the beef of other youtuber like
it's and the the Internet is great
because it really does allow people to
really feel and listen did it electrum
yeah there are certain I'm not saying
that there's absolutely no effect but if
you look at what Trump has done he's
done a lot of things but there's a lot
of things that just haven't changed and
won't change and still any you see
people that are like cognizant
politically for the first time they're
they're all like wait wait a minute
but Trump said it was gonna be a wall
and Wall Street was gonna be reined in
and we're gonna get a new health care
plan it folks it this isn't what happens
you gotta grow up a little bit the
people that are in those positions make
it very very difficult to make any real
change it's just the [ __ ] way it is
so what we do when we focus on Candace
Owen take Candace Owen say something
about Hitler what it Roseanne tweed oh I
can't believe Kyle khushu this 1700 I
had no idea who he was but he said the
n-word and these are the things you vote
you don't focus on what's truly
happening behind the scenes because you
don't know it's kept from you comes out
in a book ten years later or if you're
really really plugged in and you pay
attention you can you can figure out
some of what's happening you know like
somebody that I I uh I think it was the
chick on chapo amber said it was a you
know hardcore Marxist or whatever but
she goes I love the Financial Times more
than the New York Times she goes because
I actually glean more information it's a
better publication I learn more about
what's gonna happen in the world the
Financial Times is the world as it is
and the New York Times is that you know
editorialized rosy view of like well we
thing of the law and the Financial Times
this is up this is down we need a
pipeline to the Caspian Sea energy
prices of crashing we might need to get
a little cute in a certain area we might
need to go over there like so there are
ways to figure out this information but
it is it is funny to me how much of it
is theater and and I know that people
get mad at me because you're like well
what am I supposed to do not care about
anything yes yeah yes I yes
now I'm kidding listen care about what
you can care about I don't people tell
me all the time like what does it mean
so we shouldn't get health care like no
we should have health care like what
what are you even saying how does it
lunch today somebody strictly put it on
me for no reason I'm eating the pokeball
they go in on me sir dude your nerve
okay no we should we should we should
also not torture people in underground
prisons I prefer if we didn't
assassinate democratically elected
leaders in our own country and around
the world I would like us to stop
poisoning people murdering journalists I
would enjoy all of that I would like if
we stop sending paramilitary death
squads into other countries so that they
could make way for our corporations
going to pillage people all of that and
health care would be nice it would be
very positive for this country but I'm
telling you how things like it is what
it is the world is what it is the things
that I know that people have had on the
[ __ ] show the discussions that we've
had the debate like the areas that we've
gone into you start to get a little
coarsened by this you start talking
about human trafficking you start
talking about what's going on
you get a little corset and it's not
that difficult to like imagine that like
oh maybe some of these senators or
congressmen don't really care about
giving us elf care because they're being
blackmailed because they're in the
kiddie porn and they're doing blow so
maybe they don't really give a [ __ ]
maybe they don't care I care but here's
the thing people like what do you not
care I can't I had people on this show I
had a gave them the platform gave him a
play
I had well researched writers come on
the show who dedicated their lives to
researching how corrupt and [ __ ] our
government was and you know what people
said they said we don't want to listen
to this we want something else give us
something else give us a dope queen and
the guy we fought to give us something
else give us a pod save America we were
going elsewhere
this ain't fun for the young
professionals going to their cubicles
they don't like that they don't like
that with their matcha latte and really
like hearing about senators boinkin kids
and getting paid off and [ __ ] slaying
Kenny so I try and try I bring people on
we did a lot we did a long ride podcast
you know showed up not a lot of people
we did one for truTV we brought russ
Baker on he was [ __ ] all over the
place I think he was kind of drunk but
this is what happens when they cash you
out of [ __ ] polite society and you
can't talk to anyone you have a few